[cello music playing]
>>Dor Abrahamson:
What is mathematics
if you think about it?
Mathematics is a
way of thinking.
It's a way of solving problems.
I'm Dor Abrahamson.
I'm a professor of mathematics
education over at U.C. Berkeley.
I study the way that
kids learn mathematics.
I'm also an inventor.
I build all kind of gadgets
using both traditional
and cutting-edge technology
to help kids learn
and teachers teach.
Usually when people think
about math, they think about,
you know, X and Y and numbers
and doing all these
calculations.
However, mathematics is about
making sense of the world
and unless we can sort of
ground all of the scribbling
in something concrete
that we really get,
we'll never understand
what we're doing.
Like adding, you
know what adding is.
Take one and one and woo!
You have two.
Or if you think about
multiplication,
it's like you take, "what
is five times three?"
Three and three and
three and three.
You have a sense of
what this thing is.
But beyond that, do
people have a sense
or are they only scribbling
around and getting answers
but not really understanding
what these things are?
My job is to help kids connect
between what their brain
already knows to do and the math
that they are being taught,
so that they can do much more
than just scribble little
numbers and symbols,
so that they can really get it.
So they can go out
into the world
and identify those
phenomena, see those patterns,
use math in their lives
to solve the problems
that they care about.
Any researcher of math
education can tell you
that the big crisis starts
when fractions enter the scene.
Up to then it's just been
counting numbers: one, two,
three, four until you
get all these weird kind
of relationships where one-half
is bigger than one-third,
is bigger than one-quarter
is bigger
than one-fifth even though
the numbers are going
up the fractions
are getting smaller.
Kids flip.
Kids suddenly lose a sense
of what these things are.
>>Ratio and proportion
are everywhere.
Even on my cello.
When you take a string, play it,
and then you halve it,
it's the same note.
What we need is to help kids
see the world mathematically.
So our way of going about
solving this problem is
to develop what we
are calling the
Mathematical Imagery Trainer.
We've set this up so that
as long as the crosshair
on the right is double-height
of the crosshair on the left,
it's going to be green.
So if I move it this way,
it will keep being green.
However, if I find a green spot
and I keep the distance
the same, it will go red.
That means we can struggle with
the core learning challenge
of ratio and proportion
even before we introduce a
single number.
In our lab we are creating all
these sophisticated devices.
But we count on teachers
to bring these things
alive in their classrooms.
All you need is to be creative
as all teachers are in figuring
out how to make these
ideas come alive.
So just like with the
Mathematical Imagery Trainer,
kids saw how the distances
between their hands
keep on growing.
We can show that
just with blocks.
We can show the same
idea instead of growing
up vertically, going
horizontally.
Imagine you're leaving home
and you're driving one thing,
say a bicycle, and your
buddy is driving a car.
As you're moving along, you're
each going at a constant rate
but the distance between
you keeps growing.
This guy is moving
two units at a time
for every one unit
this guy is moving.
That's proportion.
You can use anything.
It's those images that
they'll be carrying
out through their lives.
Not the numbers.
They'll forget the procedures.
We want kids to be masters of
their mathematical knowledge
so that they can solve
the problems of the world.